Let's see if we can write
12.98 as a mixed number.
So the first thing you
might want to realize here
is that this is the exact
same thing as 12 plus 0.98.
And this simplifies it,
because then we just
have to write it as 12, and
to some fraction, that's
the same thing as 0.98.
So if we could write
0.98 as a fraction,
then we're almost done.
So let's see if we can do that.
So this 9 right over here
is in the tenths place.
I'll just write it like that.
Tenths place.
And this right over here
is in the hundredths place.
So you could view 0.98
two different ways.
You could view it as 9/10.
That's this part
right over here.
9/10 plus 8/100.
And if you want to find
a common denominator that
would be the same thing as
90 over 100 plus 8 over 100,
which is equal to 98 over 100.
And so 0.98 is 98/100.
And another way you could
have said that is look,
the space right over here
is in the hundredths place,
and so this is 98/100 or 98/100.
So you could have skipped
this right over here.
So if we just wanted to
write it as a mixed number,
we could just write
it as 12 and, instead
of 0.98, 12 and 98/100.
Now we haven't reduced
this to lowest terms yet.
So let's see if we
can simplify this.
98 is divisible by
2, and so is 100.
So let's divide
both of them by 2.
They have that common factor.
So we're going to divide
both of them by 2.
And so this is the same thing as
12, and 98 divided by 2 is 49.
100 divided by 2 is 50.
And I think that's about
as far as we can do.
49 factors, it's divisible
by 7, but 50 isn't, so we've
put it in lowest terms.
So 12.98 can be written as a
mixed number, 12 and 49/50.